now when you start to look at some of
the other statistics like bitcoins held
by strong hands
what you can see is that over the last
couple of months
uh pretty much since like the middle of
may we've seen these
strong hands continue to buy a bitcoin
you see with the green arrows there uh
you can see that there's
more and more bitcoin that is going into
the strong hands
all of the selling for the most part
over the last couple of months has been
from
new market entrance people who have been
around for six months or less holding
those bitcoin
and so what we got were new market
entrants that were buying bitcoin in the
last six months and then turning around
and selling it again the strong hands
continued to accumulate though what we
know is that the strong hands part of
the reason why they're considered
strong hands is because when they get
the bitcoin they don't turn around and
they sell it they hold it
they contribute to the supply shock they
take supply
off of the exchanges and then when new
demand comes in that ends up leading to
this kind of price
uh shock and so we also have historical
context for this we go back to 2013
jeff ross founder and ceo of vale sheer
capital
had this quote uh talking about 2013
where he said quote
following a troubling three months of
news and price action
bitcoin went on to print five monthly or
green monthly candles in a row
and went up about 10x in the second half
of 2013. now
past performance is not an indicator of
future performance
and we by no means contribute at all
financial advice
but what we do think is interesting is
that history sometimes rhymes and so
jeff here was pointing out the fact that
after three months of news and price
action that was troubling bitcoin had
five green monthly candles and went up
about 10x in the second half of 2013.
well we can look at a chart and he
provided this chart
along with it and what you see is that
there are
a succession of green monthly candles in
2013
and then if you look in 2021 we
see again a succession of monthly green
candles now
we do not know what is going to happen
in the future but what we can do is we
can look to the past
to try to get a better sense for what
we're seeing now
anybody who invests in finance whether
it is in the stock market in bitcoin
or in any other assets will tell you
that being a student of history
will provide incredible foundation of
knowledge
to understand what is happening today
and what is potentially going to happen
in the future but there is no guarantee
but a very very interesting data point
here and so then if we go and we look at
two more charts that basically show us
the amount of bitcoin that is actually
on the exchanges remember
if it's dropping if there's less and
less bitcoin on the exchanges
then it means that it is less likely
that the price can stay at the current
level if demand increases and so we can
see here from yellowblock.io
that the supply on the far right side
here you can see the supply
of bitcoin on exchanges continues to
drop it's the lowest it's been
in about two years and so another data
point showing not only
is there an increasing amount of bitcoin
in the illiquid entities
but also the supply on the exchanges
itself continues to drop
and if we zoom out even further in the
second chart what you can see
is you can actually see over a long
period of time
we are at one of if not the lowest
levels of the supply
on exchanges so if all of a sudden
we see an increase in demand that could
come from a whole
different host of events it could be
because there's more
monetary policy or fiscal policy
decisions that are made that
make people worried about higher levels
of inflation they want to go find a
store value asset
there may be things around censorship or
some sort of government overreach that
make them want to hold a censorship
resistant asset it could be things
outside of the united states that drive
adoption like a country
like el salvador going ahead and making
it legal tender or it could be a
multitude of other reasons including
simply just pure speculation
where wall street firms or other
investment firms believe the value is
going to go up in the future because of
some of the data that we're showing here
and therefore decide to start buying and
it's almost a self-fulfilling prophecy
because their increase in demand
and large dollars ends up driving the
price up regardless of what the increase
in demand could be
again we're not saying it's going to
happen but if it does happen
there is likely to be a price increase
given the fact that the supply continues
to draw down
the amount of bitcoin on exchanges
continues to draw down and
more and more strong hands are getting
their hands
pun intended on bitcoin so that they can
hold it
and so when you start to look at this
this is all happening at the exact same
time
that miners were kicked out of china
china made the decision to go ahead and
say you know what
we aren't as cool with this industry and
so over the last few months
as china went ahead and put kind of a
more serious ban in place and really
started to act on it
what we saw was the hash rate of bitcoin
completely fall off a cliff
there was almost a 50 percent reduction
give or take
in the actual hash rate so you can see
that we had pretty much been trending up
since 2019
uh the bottoming of that hatch rate on
up and
bitcoin is the most powerful computer
network in the world it's the most
secure computer network in the world it
has more computing power directed
towards it than any other computer
network in the world
that is true both at the top there uh
kind of early 2021
and also after a 50 decline now we saw
that there was a bottoming out
a week or two ago and now we've started
to rapidly
come back and so we today sit with the
hash rate
at about the october 2020 low so if you
were to take a line and draw it from
where we are today back you would hit
the low that we hit in october 2020.
not bad given the fact that one of the
largest countries in the world
kicked out a very high percentage of
hash rate from their country right we're
only set back
about eight months or so give or take
and so what we see is the bitcoin supply
continues to operate
exactly how it is 21 million bitcoin we
continue to put 900 bitcoin a day
into the actual circulating supply but
the addressable circulating supply the
supply available for buying and selling
on exchanges
continues to shrink the hash rate has
now bottomed and continued to recover
and what i think this is laying out is a
very
very attractive underlying fundamentals
that suggest if demand continues to
increase in the future given the macro
environment
speculation and other types of drivers
of demand
the price is likely to continue which
means that the bull market is still
intact joe and john you two are both
bitcoin bulls as well how do you guys
look at this data what do you think that
it's telling us when you start to kind
of
unpack some of the supply the supply
squeeze thesis and then also the the
hash rate
yeah for me i think a lot of the the
metrics especially on chain and stuff
can get confusing at times but
when you just think about it in the the
context of supply and demand it makes a
whole lot more sense right so there's 50
to 60
of bitcoin haven't moved in a year uh
the illiquid supply
on the exchanges has drastically uh uh
increased over time there's less coin
less bitcoin available so when you look
at it the fundamental is exactly what
you just said
it suggests that the bull run isn't over
and when you overlay it when you're
looking at 2013 and 2017
uh it's very very very similar in
context and it suggests that we're going
higher than 60.
just any any kind of increase in demand
it could be anything that you mentioned
previously
but any kind of shock on the demand side
is going to drastically increase price
just given the supply it's currently
available on exchanges
the other piece of this that uh is
really interesting is who's buying it so
we can see here the strong hands
it's not so much just the supply is
drawing down like the the um kind of
liquid supply or the addressable supply
but it's also the people who are going
to hold this stuff
uh hold the bitcoin historically have
shown a high propensity for not selling
they are strong hands
and so when john i think you looked up
the uh the statistics
it's like 56 of bitcoin hasn't moved in
the last 12 months even though bitcoin
went from 10
000 to 60 back down to 30 and now sits
at 40
more than 50 percent of bitcoin holders
aren't selling they're not moving the
bitcoin
yeah it's also important to mention
who's buying it right so as we saw a
bunch of institutions come in
they have larger wallets whales all
those people
um it's really important to see that
like look
as a company you don't want to take a if
it goes from 60 to
30 000 you can't take a loss right or do
you sell it and kind of hedge out your
um
your loss so this is a wild stat 10 of
bitcoin supply hasn't moved in a decade
10 that was as of december 18 2020 so
it's a little outdated now
uh given kind of the increase in supply
but as of the end of last year
1.85 million bitcoin hadn't moved in a
decade
so that is impressive do we know does it
include satoshi's coins
i think satoshi's wallet has about 800
000 bitcoin in it and
you know satoshi showing uh showing
their face
uh and they're not moving any coins so
if that includes the satoshi wallet
um it's about a million bitcoin outside
of satoshi right that haven't moved in
over a decade which is still incredible
right in terms of uh how much bitcoin
has not moved
um in that long period i mean we're
talking about from literally pennies to
today
at uh you know tens of thousands of
dollars one thing that's i guess
important i'm asking you is
if he ever moved his coins right the
price would just
uh drop basically like overnight right
almost like a rug pole if he ever
decided to sell something i don't think
so if satoshi ended up moving the
bitcoin in the wallet i think that there
would be
a price drop like immediately but i
think it would recover pretty quickly
and it would be more the surprise rather
than the action
uh but i don't think that satoshi moving
the coins would really matter that much
in terms of the long-term health of the
network on top of that i don't think
that
it really matters who satoshi is at this
point uh i think
there's a huge advantage to the fact we
don't know who satoshi is
but uh if we somehow found out who it
was
i don't think anyone is going to sell
their bitcoin because of who it is
or they're going to go buy bitcoin
because of who it is uh including if it
was
anyone from an individual an
organization a nation state or you know
anyone else
i think that the idea of bitcoin the
fact that it is decentralized that it's
not controlled by anyone that has a
programmatic transparent monetary policy
is unlikely to be um
kind of uh inferior to the fact of who
the founder is you know 12 13 years
later
yeah well when you start to think about
it in the context of what are the
estimates it's like three and a half to
four million bitcoin are lost forever
they they think
so that's 15 to 20 percent of current
supply add that on top of ones that
haven't moved in a decade or the 50
that haven't moved in a year and you
start to think about it from a supply
perspective it's pretty
uh enticing
is the word i would use i mean this was
the thesis in 2019 going into 2020 was
basically there's going to be the supply
shock not a supply squeeze a supply
shock and the shock was that we're gonna
get the bitcoin having in may of 2020.
we'd go from 1800 bitcoin a day to 900
bitcoin
you're going to have at least the same
demand right
we ended up actually getting an
explosion of demand because the macro
environment
and that led to this massive price
increase from eight thousand think about
that from eight thousand
to sixty four thousand dollars from the
having until the top in uh march april
time frame or may or whatever it was
and then we came back down to 30 right
and now back to 40. i thought the having
was priced in
uh well there are some people who
believe that the having is priced in
uh as we know one of the greatest
uh scams in the financial system is the
market efficiency hypothesis or the
efficient market hypothesis
which basically believes that the market
is an efficient tool because everyone
has access to the same information
now you would have to believe when the
market is efficient which it is not and
two you would have to believe that
everyone has access to the same
information
and three you would also have to believe
that everyone who has access to the same
information comes to the same conclusion
of that information
and so there are many people who hold
bitcoin today who don't even know what
the having is
they couldn't explain what the having is
they couldn't tell you what the impact
historically of the having has been
nor could they even tell you what the
incoming daily supply of bitcoin was
before or
after the having and so therefore it is
impossible
for it to be priced in because
all of the participants in the market
are not acting on the same information
nor are they ingesting the information
coming to the same conclusion either
so from a basic definition the efficient
market hypothesis
is invalid and also there is
zero percent chance zero percent chance
that people can believe the havings are
priced in because everyone doesn't know
about it so if everyone could also just
look at the charts
and see what it's done after every
having price-wise that would be pretty
easy well but you do you know that uh
you're just uh historically saying that
you have hindsight buys that's why it
happened it's not because of the having
it's gonna happen next time too
i mean do we think that there's always
gonna be this massive impact of the
having
i i definitely think there will always
be a positive impact
because you have a supply shock you
can't have a supply shock and have
zero impact in the market that's not how
markets work right
supply demand if you cut the supply in
half and demand stays the same
even just staying the same the price is
going to continue to increase
if demand increases which historically
it has
over time post the shock then the price
will
drastically increase which is exactly
what we saw play out here
you